[Music]
our next speaker is Susan Holmes is a
great pleasure to have her today she's a
professor at Stanford she's very
interested in developing new
computational and statistical approaches
to our rather complex biological
datasets and today she's gonna tell us
about challenges posed by geologists of
the human microbiome thanks ok thank you
thank you for inviting me only invite me
to Boston in October so all I have to
say I lived here for three years okay so
I got really interested in microbiome
about more than ten years ago and the
challenge here is multi-domain data and
that's really what I'm interested in
that is heterogeneous data are the
challenge of everything that we're doing
today in in biology that is we're trying
to combine not just one source of data
people talk about big data I'm not
interested in that I think that the
multi domain is the the challenge and
the data I'm going to talk to you about
today comes from several projects that
I'm involved in I have a large grant
with David relman to study resilience
and perturbations in the human
microbiome and I also work on the March
of Dimes study of preterm pregnancy and
so we're trying to look at perturbations
our longitudinal data and I'll explain a
little bit some of the challenges a lot
of them have to do with the quality of
the different types of data that come in
the different types of noise the graph
and tree integration and elements that
usually you couldn't just put in a
Euclidean distance in a in a standard
way and then I am very wedded to
reproducibility so all of my code and
all the data I'm going to talk about
that it's been published is already
publicly available so what are the data
so happily we already had a talk at
lunch time about the human microbiome
and
by Oda and so I want to talk I agree
completely that it's the place where
medicine meets ecology I think that's an
interesting explanation and the
different types of data that we have
come different levels so with there's
one gene which is called the 16s RNA
gene which serves as a signature
fingerprint for all the different
species of bacteria and so that's one
which we concentrate a lot on there's
also the fact that you can just shotgun
and sequence everything that's there and
look at all the genes and that's called
the meta genome and you can do what we
do on other types of data RNA SEC to see
what's expressed by all these different
genes and we do a lot of mass spec as
well to look at the proteomics and then
there's a lot of clinical variables and
environmental variables which are really
important like diet and you know time
seasonal effects and things like that we
have a lot of domain knowledge that you
can't just ignore so some people in feel
as if in order to be objective you have
to be dumb and so you have to pretend
that you only know one thing at a time
and that is just a big mistake so you're
throwing out a lot of information and
you want to take into account everything
you know in the way you analyze the data
and that's one of the things that we
really try to do that is integrate
networks or phylogenetic trees into the
way that we compare things and I like
that here there hasn't been a single
talk where people have talked about
metadata they talk about phenotypes and
I'm with you that is there's a whole
field of bioinformatics who've left who
let the NSA carry on with their metadata
and this isn't really data everything
you collect is data and you have to
integrate it so we have to find out how
to combine the data of different types
now we've written a computational system
around our and bioconductor which makes
heterogeneous data objects where you
don't lose any of the links between the
clinical variables the phylogenetic tree
the taxa the samples across time
and that's been very important from a
more mathematical point of view and
since you know we're trying to look at
the computations I think it's useful to
think about many of these data sets
although it's not economical for graphs
for instance but think about them as
matrices so you have many matrices you
might have time series the same subjects
over time so you can consider them as
matrices of counts you might have
posterior distributions there are many
matrices over time networks in
longitudinal studies they're still
matrices it's a good way of thinking
about them mathematically and this data
is always finite so we don't have to do
too much you know infinite matrices now
I was brought up in a French Dogma and
so I'm going to make you support it for
a few minutes I don't think like a
probabilistic math statistician I'm a
data analysis and I think about
everything geometrically so for me we
have two dual spaces you have the space
of the variables say abundances of taxa
and all the samples lie in that space
and then you have the other side of
things where you can look at the
variables as measured for each of the
different samples now that duality is
actually useful we we create inner
products on both spaces and you just
decide which space you care about and
often it's by cheating on the dimension
that is you look at the dimension which
is very large and you're going to not
you know you that's not the
dimensionality of your problem if you
only have 50 samples the dimensionality
can't be bigger than 50 so people say oh
you know we have 40,000 variables yeah
but it still sits in 50 dimensions so
you don't have to worry about having so
many things you're measuring it just
depends on you know what side of what
projection you make but if you use any
kind of spectral method or kernel
methods that actually matters it brings
down the dimensionality so I haven't you
know we have a geometrical or
to that and we can put metrics on and
this really matters when you do data
integration you have to care about how
much information how much weighting
you're putting on all the different
variables because they're going to have
a different effect and if you feel as if
you know in one domain you have much
more information than in another domain
you want to take that into account this
is a little bit similar to if you have
high variance high variability on one
variable you may not want to make
exactly all the variances be 1 so the
rescaling of the tables and rescaling of
the variables they're a little bit
similar it's just you know in spades in
some way so the standard methods and
many people who've talked here already
talked about pca and dimension reduction
they're all based on you take it inner
product you take the eigen decomposition
or you know the cross product matrix and
then you take a couple of eigen
functions and you project the data down
now you might do that in different ways
but basically that's a simple framework
and so I call that generalized PCA but
you know that this is very standard and
very easy to do on the computer and what
we're going to try and do is just change
a little bit the metrics that we put in
the s and the V that are here and we're
going to change them so that we
integrate more information about the
relationships between the variables that
we get so this is a duality diagram we
call and this is why you can go back and
forth as I was saying before between
which of the operators you diagonalize
and it doesn't it just to say that you
can frame many of the standard
statistical methods in the same way so
one of the interesting ones and one
which will extrapolate in some sense it
is discriminant analysis so
discriminant analysis isn't the same as
pca just in the fact that you don't look
for the directions the eigenvectors that
maximize the simple variance you want to
maximize the variance between the groups
and you're given a group variation
variability and usually you're given
labels for the groups and you just want
to try and spread out those labels so
you can actually write down the
discriminant analysis and that's useful
in some way as a decomposition with this
same communicative diagram it's just you
have a different metric and you have a
metric for instance it takes into
account here we have the total variation
and then you have the winning class
variation which also occurs and then
we're going to just diagonalize a
different matrix and we have a different
weighting scheme but you can think of
discriminant analysis as a special case
of pca
i want to do something a little bit
different i want to not completely take
perfect groups into account i have
groups that appear along a tree so i'm
going to do something a little bit more
sophisticated yeah no it's the other way
around so discriminant analysis is a
special case of generalized pca
discriminant analysis is eigen
decomposition and you can put in the
weights here this triplet here so that
this is a pca but it gives you the
discriminant variables and if you could
think about it this way think that
you're giving special weights and you
take the mean points of each of the
groups and you do pca with regards to
that and you have a special weighting
and it's that's the same thing but it
it's useful when you want to go to sort
of intermediary so as i said we're going
to look at many matrices over time and
here i've put in here
some of the information that we'd like
to take into account so for the taxa the
different species we know phylogenetic
trees these are given to us for genetic
networks we have genetic interactions we
have protein protein interactions or
genetic reactions that we we can induce
and we already know and when you're
doing functional data for instance if
you have mass spec metabolic data you
know the metabolic networks so we
actually want to use metrics which take
all of those into account the earliest
way of doing this was to D to say
everything is distances and if we can
make the right distance then we can make
low dimensional representation of these
distances and this actually came from
the work of Schoenberg and the idea
there is to say you're given a matrix
it's symmetric positive numbers we're
going to find the points in Euclidean
space which are have distances which are
as close as possible to those given
distances and so that method is called
multi-dimensional scaling in one word
world
it's called PCA in the world of ecology
and that's been the workhorse of most of
the early work on microbial ecology is
based on this P Co a now the secret
sauce here is the distance that is you
have to choose a distance which is
relevant for your data so people use
break curtiss distance there are
actually forty different distances from
which to choose to from it so it's quite
troubling because in some sense you
already have to know what you're looking
for there's some metric learning sort of
inference in there when you are choosing
your distance but there is a way to take
into account the distance on the tree
between the species and then doing a PC
a PC Oh a on those points so the way
that works and this is called double
principle coordinate now the system that
was
first developed by ecologist and my PhD
student Elizabeth Purdham developed it
for the microbiome and that's that
you're given the samples are at
different locations say and that look at
those locations you have measurements of
abundances of all the taxa and you have
a relationship between a tree
relationship between the taxa so you
start by taking the distance on the tree
between this the species you build a
coordinate space Euclidian and then you
take the points the abundances as the
weights on the coordinate spaces and so
that's a little bit abstract let me show
you on an example but that's the idea
it's called double principle coordinate
alysus so this is what it looks like on
antibiotic time course data so in this
first preliminary study that David
relman did there were three subjects and
there were about 2,500 different taxa
that were measured on 50 time points on
these three subjects we're trying to
understand the time points corresponding
there were two courses of antibiotics
are trying to understand the resilience
that is some of the subjects change
under antibiotic stress the abundances
of the bacteria and so the way that I
just said we take the Fulani or the
relationship between the different taxa
which is known and you can make a
multi-dimensional scaling a PCO a of
those points and then take each of these
points and their abundances and take
those as the weights and then you get a
representation of all the samples so the
first thing you see here is the green
the red and the blue the colors are all
the different subjects
now the first thing about the microbiome
is the only thing that matters if you're
trying to differentiate is the person
every person has their own ecology there
are lots of degrees of freedom and we're
all very different so that
is the main motivation why all the
studies I'm going to show you a
longitudinal that is you can only really
use the person as their own control when
you're doing a perturbation study and
this is the relationship that we see now
what I want to show you really is what
happens with the perturbation so under
stress I'm going to make some of those
samples B of one type those will be the
stress that is when they're taking
antibiotics and just after and the other
will be what happened before and a long
time after the antibiotics so there a
one is under stress and E 2 is when
they're back to normal so what you see
is within each subject so the subject to
subject differences but there is a
tendency for these two subjects to have
the same direction they shifted in the
same way so the stress seems to be the
same here we had a particular type of
subject who was didn't react so wasn't
resilient in the same way and so these
are these representations enabled us to
see well there's something to be studied
about you know what they do together
what is common to the subjects and some
of the subjects one group of subjects
sort of don't seem to show much
difference so we did a larger study and
I'm going to show you that now and this
study just appeared in August's in plus
computational biology and here what we
wanted to do was adapt the DP coa to be
less severe that is in some sense we
don't believe that the only composer
component variants the only thing that's
moving the variability is the
phylogenetic tree we believe that you
know evolution and the tree between the
different taxa is important but we
believe there's a whole part of the
variability which isn't linked to the
tree so we wanted to modulate the tree
and so this is the the
a sparkline plot in fact every line
that's coming out of this is a time
series and I'll give you a better plot
of it and but this is the phylogenetic
tree of the different taxa that are
found so first of all we we have a this
is a small part of a larger study here
we only have eight patients we actually
have a hundred subjects that we
recruited through the quantified self so
a wonderful method for recruiting
subjects the quantified self big problem
not a demographic a good demographic
sample the quantified self it's young
men between the age of twenty-five and
thirty-five we had more than a hundred
people of these type sign up within the
first week and then we had to say no no
it won't any more of you women because
usually recruitment is a big problem so
we were very excited to begin with we
get all these people are recruiting then
we look at the profiles and they're
completely homogeneous so this is a
subset of them and these are colonic
clean outs that the subject volunteered
to do and they were as you see the time
points are not equally distributed that
is we have very heavy density and
sampling around the perturbation so
that's a carefully designed statistical
study in some sense that is in
statistics when you make an experimental
design you always collect more points
where you have high variance so high
perturbation and then outside we have
more regularly sample points and this is
not antibiotics we have several runs of
perturbations for the same subjects this
is just the colonic cleaner so here we
actually mathematically constructed a
prior which was in between the tree and
just having an ordinary variance
covariance matrix and the way we did it
is by constructing a kernel and in order
to make
colonel which sort of obeys a tree we
took Brownian motion and the correlation
is if the correlation is very high we
suppose that along the Brownian motion
the particles are staying the same along
the same path and then when they're
splitting off then they become
independent you know they're they're
losing their dependency so the length of
the branches high up in the tree tells
you how correlated the variables are so
this is quite a realistic model for for
a phylogenetic tree but it enables us to
build in some sense this kernel and I
won't belabor yes so the nodes here are
going to be the taxa yeah and and and so
we're going to build a metric such that
the covariance in some sense is you know
if the taxa wrote right down at the
bottom of the tree together they're
going to be very correlated yeah
so but that's the idea but we actually
how can I say we put a weight on the
part of which was ordinary the ordinary
variance and the part would you actually
the tree so you can modulate this is
like a one parameter family that goes
from ordinary PCA all the way to DPC
away so you can you can modulate and you
can actually get the data to tell you
what the ideal parameter you know tuning
parameter is and this is called adaptive
generalize PCA and it's Julia Fukuyama
who wrote there's a program on github
that you can use and yes sorry would it
be a memory no with what objective when
you say let the data tell you where to
interpolate between those two um well we
you can look at the different criteria
you can do it by cross-validation or you
can do it with regards to some other
information that you have in this case
we actually have a change point which we
know as I say I'm not an objective
statistician I refuse to be dumb so I
know something about this data I know
when we gave the clean-out to the
subjects so if we can find a change
point which is coherent with our data
that's what I'm looking for and this is
the output so here's the phylogenetic
tree of the different taxa these are
coefficients which actually correspond
to the taxa and they appear on the
branches is a little bit hard to see
here but here is how these different
taxa jump up and down and so here you
can see that this RSV 305 goes way down
during the perturbation and then rest'
AB lashus itself perfectly so it very
resilient taxa so we have these profiles
of these different taxa and we could see
you know that's what we're interested in
so that that enables us to see that so I
can't give you all the details in the
paper we have a darker image and three
bioconductor packages and the data set
which are all public which go with the
paper so I encourage you to ask me
questions you know offline or by email
if you want to try this out I do think
it's really important to say that
everybody could have come up with a
different method we could have done
different types of models and it would
be it's interesting to compare between
methods and so I'm open to other people
analyzing the data and telling me oh
you've got that completely wrong and so
on so we do try to make a reproducible
research workflow and you saw these RS
vs and in fact what they are I've
changed the names from ot use so why not
my field we often call MOT use there's
been a big mistake made in defining the
unit's the strains with which we work
and this was you know I took out he used
to be standard and I didn't ask how this
raw data was profiled at the beginning
and I realized that there had been a
mistake and so I'm gonna talk to you a
little bit about what we did for this
steak and this is about Dada too and so
if you want to see exactly how you use
all of this data - we did make a
complete workflow and f1000 research
which has the code so the strain level
analysis and this came up in the talk
that already gave this morning that the
we'd like to know more about certain
strains and I'll just motivate it and
tell you why we did two studies on
pregnancy and and predicting preterm and
the main thing that came out when we did
these studies was that there are certain
taxa which came out as really important
and the main one that came out was
Gardener Ella and we were able to
revisit the data and actually we took a
different class of subjects a different
ethnicity different background and we
found the same result but we also found
that it wasn't all the strains of
gardnerella that were associated with
preterm birth so that was something that
was important for us and that's why it's
sort of the attention to detail in this
case is very important so here there's
Gardiner Ellis training we were able to
do it by ignoring what I said about
distances so distances forget all the
beginning of the talk I said distances
were really important distances on
everything and this is a mistake that we
made doing Oh to use so it's much better
to have strain information then not have
strain information here when you follow
the different women you can see that the
strains stay about the same but we don't
have the strain resolution when you use
the old method so how do people build
what are called ot use they use a
distance and so if you have strains
which occur a hundred times more than
other strains the otu method takes a
radius of a fixed distance which doesn't
take into account the frequency and
that's a bad kind of distance you want a
distance which tells you whether you
have and this is one annoys me when
people you know compare women and men in
math you know Larry Summers and so on
the thing is if you don't have the same
number of baseline people you're
comparing to of course if you have
10,000 men you know you have much higher
extreme points if you have a hundred
women you're going to have much less
extreme points so the frequency
underlying is not independent
you know the extreme points are not
independent of the frequencies and this
is a mistake that everybody seems to
make and so this was a mistake that
people made on ot use and we modeled the
frequencies taking into account you know
that some of the OT you so much some of
the strains are much more frequent
you're going to see many more errors if
they're much more frequent and if you
take that into account we have this
error model and we were able to sorry
I'm going to go back to show you what
this gave us this comes from this new
probabilistic error model in which we've
incorporated the frequencies with which
you see the strains and we're able to
denoise if you have a strain which
occurs a hundred thousand times you're
going to see with some plus or error you
know five errors away will be quite
frequent within that and if you have a
sequence which is five away it's
probably just a noisy version of your
very frequent sequence so this method
has completely changed how we're able to
do this training and I wish we could do
it for metagenomics and if anybody is
interested in doing a really hard
project it would be to take this that
we've done for one gene and do it for a
whole set of marker genes and so and so
that's a paper that appeared in Nature
Methods with Ben Callahan and I don't
have time to
you about the registration that we did
to do uncertainty but I'll just show you
this picture my goal has been that when
we make these multi-dimensional
dimension of plots with PCO a we don't
use ellipses the data are never normal
you can't use ellipses but you can do
Bayesian computations which give you
Bayesian confidence intervals and here
we have confidence regions around points
by using Bayesian posteriors and it's
much better than just trying to say
everything is normally distributed which
is not so I'm going to finish thank all
the statisticians who make all their
data available in bioconductor because I
use it a lot we have a lot of different
github repos and everything to do with
phyllo sig was developed by Joey and he
has very good tutorials I work mostly
with David relman and Elizabeth Purdom
is the first person I worked with on the
microbiome and these are other people
who do proteins and that's my lab group
and I'm hiring a postdoc and I know you
can't come from Statistics because there
is no such thing but if you come from
physics I'll take you Ben Callahan I
think the physicists are the donor model
for you know people who okay that's it
thank you that's good
[Applause]